salut après un an et demi de vidéos de
spectacles et d'écriture de livres j'ai
décidé de faire une pause cet été pour
me reposer oui mais aussi pour vous
préparer une renaissance de la chaîne en
septembre vous est demandé sur twitter
si vous vouliez quelques facteurs rapide
et divertissant en attendant alors
pendant ces 60 jours de pause je vous
laisse une vidéo rapide et sans
prétention tous les jours pairs à 11
heures on se retrouve à la rentrée et
tout de suite
est ce que vous pensiez vraiment que
george washington cultiver du cannabis
salue aujourd'hui je vous parle de truc
qui m'a fait marrer quand moi je les lui
la première fois je me suis renseigné et
c'est vrai à 18 ans george washington
était cultivateur ils étaient
agriculteurs ja en virginie à cette
époque là on cultiver du coton du tabac
ou du chanvre le chanvre qui servait à
faire des cordages qui servait à faire
des vêtements et la vraie question qu'on
se pose
historiquement parlant et surtout ceux
qui font le lobby du cannabis
aujourd'hui c'est est ce qu'il le
consommer est ce que george washington
fumer son propre cannabis alors on a
retrouvé son journal et dans son journal
il ya ya ya un indice à l'intérieur en
1765 mais 65
ça a été vraiment la grande époque du
cannabis et là on sait qu'à cette
époque-là il récoltait à peu près 500 kg
est plutôt une belle production mais ce
qui est plus perturbant c'est que dans
son journal il explique comment on peut
séparer les mâles plan des mâles
femelles et ça pour faire du textile ou
des cordages
on s'en fout un peu le seul intérêt
c'est que dans les plants femelles du
cannabis et là qu'on trouve le thc qui
est la substance psychotrope active
le but du jeu c'est que le plan mal ne
feront pas le plan feu mais bon au final
on est quand même sûr de rien on n'y a
pas de vraie hypothèse sérieuse sur le
sujet puisque on peut aussi séparer les
plans mal des plants femelles simplement
parce que les plans mal ont apparemment
des fibres un peu plus solide et des
petits j'ai un petit peu plus solide
donc pour la production c'est mieux
alors que les plants femelles
elles fournissent des graines et on peut
les séparer pour se dire que on va
replanter grâce à sa peau qu'il en soit
le sujet était assez drôle et méritait
d'être abordée au moins une fois durant
cette série de l'été où je vous fais une
vidéo tous les deux jours jusqu'au 30
août
j'espère que ça vous a plu si c'est le
cas n'oubliez pas de cliquer ou de vous
abonner à la chaîne et rendez vous dans
deux jours forcément après demain ciao